okay Peter wrote in what about the idea
of randomly drawing people to decide who
are our elected officials with term
limits I've talked about random
selection for elected officials and
there's two there's two big pros and
cons for this right the positive idea of
randomly selecting our elected officials
out of a hat sort of like jury duty the
good thing is that it makes it much more
difficult to do political cronyism and
lobbying and all that type of thing
because when you really have random
individuals who not may not even be
connected to a particular political
party or whatever it's going to be much
more difficult for it to be worth
spending a ton of lobbying dollars if
you are kind of disaggregating this
political apparatus of the big
Republican Party and the Democratic
Party although presumably you could be
randomly picking from registered voters
or whoever right so it'll be likely that
the Republicans are Democrats anyway so
the idea is you mate you D incentivize
the sort of deal-making that is a big
problem within politics and that would
be a good reason it would also make it
so that when you're an elected official
you're less likely to make decisions
based on promises around re-election
donations campaign funds whatever
because you're term-limited you've got
some other career you're just there for
two four or six years however many it is
and then you're out right so that's the
that's the argument in favor of randomly
selecting elected officials the downside
is that while it's true that the types
of people that get into politics we
could argue and have some data
suggesting are disproportionately
sociopathic and lack empathy
disproportionately from certain fields
like law for example or other fields
that are more common for elected
officials that's bad but at the same
time you do need certain types to be
elected officials and to be able to
relate to lots of different people in
different ways and to be in diverse
situations of both public speaking and
and working with individuals you're
going to get a lot of randomly selected
people that are just not cut out for
some really basic elements of the job
and we could argue well you don't really
need to be it's you shouldn't have to be
good with people to be an elected
official you own it particularly if
you're not running
for an election you only need to be a
good legislator but being a good
legislator also depends on building
relationships with your other
legislators etc so I do worried that we
are going to be putting people in there
that at some structural level lack some
important skills and I think a good
example is think about some of the
people you know whatever horrible things
we can think about lots of elected
officials right Donald Trump for example
or Devin Nunez right whoever we don't
like in politics imagine you know that
weird cousin of yours who says
completely crazy stuff at Thanksgiving
what if they're your senator for the
next six years I think that there's
significant risk of that so I'm against
it but I am in favor of term limits I
think that that's a good idea I don't
know if you're for or against this
random picking thing pretty against it
and maybe it has to do with you know
more of a practical purpose too because
you know it's not as if passing a bill
or appropriating funds is as easy as you
may think it should be that's true
there's so much rigmarole when it comes
to just like Senate procedures House
procedures that I don't think the
average citizen can do it counterpoint
couldn't you rely more you know how when
you have someone sit in as Speaker of
the House they don't know everything
they're supposed to say they have aides
there with a piece of paper and they're
like holding up each thing that the
acting you know senate president whoever
speaker the house has to say you could
keep that same core staff right which
would know hey listen we're net we're no
longer working with professional
politicians so we have to do more to
prepare them or whatever but I get what
you're saying I mean it is definitely a
problem I mean I guess in a hypothetical
scenario where we dissolve Congress and
put in this like lottery system yep it's
also easy to assume that we could make
it a little bit more straightforward
yeah that's true that provided I'd you
know consider it but still wouldn't be
in supportive I'm not in support of it
I'm really not I do think that there are
other ways to stimulate the inclusion of
people from different backgrounds within
the House and Senate and part of it has
to do with parties deciding hey we are
gonna more actively recruit people from
fields other than law and what are like
the other common laws the one that comes
to mind but what are the common that
actually I feel like there's a bunch of
physicians yeah there are kind of a
bunch of interesting and they usually
tout that as saying because I'm
doctor I can tell you the best way to
completely dismantle Obamacare yeah I
mean I think we have the path forward
it's you know limiting money in politics
it's eliminating gerrymandering yep I
think we have the right solution to this
I don't think we have to go this drastic
term limits though are you for or again
I'm for turma I'm for them as well and I
know that some people say you are going
to kick good people out of politics with
term limits we are still going to have
plenty in a country of 340 million
people plenty of people who are both
competent and qualified and interested
in serving if we term limit that's very
different than just randomly sorting
people so those are my thoughts Peter
thanks to everybody for the audience
questions get yours in david at david
pakman.com twitter facebook Instagram
patreon smoke signals whatever you want
send us the questions and we'll keep
answering them talk to you on the bonus
show